Karen Warren la talk radio
well you know I'm fascinated in insert
the human process and part of you know
when I was writing it was also a
journalist and I wrote deep features you
know that you know appeared in Texas
Monthly and austin american-statesman
and you know I've had been in New York
Times in Esquire and so I'm very
interested in that human process and how
that union process sort of transforms
character as a writer it sort of allows
me to sort of set up the base blocks of
story and by understanding the base and
the root of story I think that you can
do anything and so for me writing sort
of took me all the way back to the
beginning of a process and of course as
we all know that film is this creative
process that's got to start somewhere
and in somewhere so you know writing is
helped tremendously